it's the final season so it's a pretty
long long one reelected in our time with
this one and then got another HBO movie
coming up summer kind of sad to be
saying goodbye to Tyrion and he's such a
beloved character and I mean I know
everybody a lot of people in this room
were obsessed with show myself yeah is
it kind of yeah it's bittersweet it's
always time to move on with everything
so it's the sad part of our business we
get you know pockets of great people for
a short amount of time and then you have
to move on and it's always heartbreaking
especially when you've spent more than a
couple months with people but uh yeah
it's time you know and they're actually
there their story wise not just for our
all our lives but I think if they went
any further it would start to it's a
perfect timing to end it sometimes shows
stay on a little too long yeah the
jumping the shark they agree yeah
I've think there's gonna be a
bittersweet ending and I've always taken
my influence from junior Tolkien and if
you've read Lord of the Rings Sauron is
defeated in the ring is destroyed in the
end but it's not a happy happy ending
there's there's a real sense of things
lost too and and I found that very
powerful and very moving and so I think
my ending will also have a bittersweet
tone I hope if I can bring it off the
way I want to bring it off the Wars of
the Roses are the probably the single
biggest influence so I've drawn from
French history and Scottish history and
other things but at the center of it all
is the Wars of the Roses you know I have
the Lannisters and the Starks and in
real life it was the Lancaster's in New
York's but and I've changed things
around a little I've mixed and matched
I've taken a bit of that character a bit
of that character to create my own
characters willfully stand on their own
but the influence of British history is
huge
hey everybody if you guys didn't know
Sundance is happening right now so Peter
Dinklage is up there promoting another
movie naturally because it's the final
season of Game of Thrones people are
asking him all about the episodes so
he's talking about bittersweet ending I
also added that George our Martin
bittersweet ending interview for context
that was actually done a while ago
but Peter Dinklage actually did give us
some functional information about what's
going on with season 8 induced to
provide a general update since we got
that last big one from the TC A's panel
so if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos I'm also doing a new round of the
DVD giveaway at the end of this so the
funny thing about this Peter Dinklage
interview is that you have Elle Fanning
off to the side just like giggling maybe
because she thinks it's funny that
people keep asking Peter Dinklage about
Game of Thrones or she's just so excited
herself about Game of Thrones like you
have to imagine Peter Dinklage is a
great actor by himself but when he's
talking about Game of Thrones stuff
pretty much everybody in the room gets
excited because everybody in the world
wants to see the final season but in
addition to all the bitter sweetness
that he's talking about he also says
that currently they're about halfway
done through filming which also lines up
with things that sir Davos and sophie
Turner said a couple months ago about
what the schedule would actually be
they'll be filming right up into the
summer and then they'll spend the rest
of this year in post-production I've
already done a video for what the
president of HBO said about their 2019
premiere plans and what he said about
the prequel series so I'll link that
video at the end of this but thankfully
even though they haven't given up any
big spoilers or anything like that
they've been pretty forthcoming about
what the timetable is what they're doing
right now like the really big moves that
they're making when Peter Dinklage is
talking about them taking their time I
know everybody wants episodes faster but
what he's talking about is he just means
that they're not rushing through scenes
like they're taking the time to actually
get it right so if somebody just has a
completely take they just try it
till they get it right which is what you
would typically do on a movie set like
you just keep doing it takes David
Fincher style till you get something
that's really good just goes back to the
quality over quantity scenario which is
really where we are with season 8
because Dan and Dave are like yeah we
could stretch this out for another 10
years if we wanted to and if you don't
remember there's this now infamous quote
from the head of AMC from a year or two
ago who said that the Walking Dead could
go on for another 10 years so just keep
in mind the fan backlash behind that
series this past year and what would
potentially happen to the fandom if HBO
decided to stretch out the Song of Ice
and Fire narrative for another 10 years
that's what the prequel series are for
like you won another 10 years of Game of
Thrones but you don't want them to
destroy a really
some story in pursuit of that HBO also
created a little bit of confusion
recently when they also said that there
would be no spin-off series but in
context what they meant what they said
that is that none of the pre-existing
characters would spin off into their own
series like there would be no Daenerys
series set after Game of Thrones
following Daenerys as character there
would be no Jon Snow series so just to
be clear they're just differentiating
between that terminology spin-off
meaning spinoff with existing characters
so the prequel series technically are
not spin-offs but a lot of people refer
to them that way so just to be clear
there will be another Game of Thrones
series but it's going to be a prequel it
won't be a spin-off do not worry it
sounds more confusing that it is but
Peter Dinklage puts it pretty succinctly
when he says that they would be headed
for a shark jump scenario but the
bittersweet endings that he talks about
in the gorge are Martin talk about are a
little bit different in context when
Peters talking about bittersweet he's
acknowledging yes it'll be bittersweet
for the characters but mostly he's
talking about for the actors in real
life they've been working together in
close quarters for so long some of the
younger actresses like Maisie Williams
and sophie Turner grew up on the show
this was taken I think back in 2010
before season 1 started look at how
young all these stark actors look now
obviously some of them will go on to
other different series and they'll work
together in various capacities but none
of them will be together in the way they
are for Game of Thrones right now which
happens with a lot of long-running TV
series so it's kind of sad for the
actors like we'll see each other again
but it won't quite be the same thing
when Martin talks about the bittersweet
token ending he's not talking so much
about plot it's not gonna be a carbon
copy of Return of the King he's talking
more about a hollow victory scorched
earth victory like the scouring of the
shire so you beat the ultimate villain
but at what great cost so that gets into
more of what the series is actually
about like from a conflict standpoint
and why i think the show opted to
elevate Cersei to secret Big Bad status
instead of the night king which it's
been marketing as the main villain of
the series so two different things like
HBO like when they send out marketing
materials they put the knight Kings face
on it like oh we have to unite against
the knight king but way back during
season one there's this clip where
they're talking about what the show is
really about
in context with all the supernatural
stuff that's going on in lands of
Perpetual ice and cold a supernatural
threat is stirring after centuries of
sleep the things used to be called
they've been gone for thousands of years
sleep sleeping Game of Thrones is a
fantasy world and there is magic but
that's not about monsters it's about
humans so think about that when you're
theorycrafting what the ending of the
series will be for example we talked
about the list of directors for the
final six episodes what types of
episodes those directors have done in
the past for Game of Thrones in what it
says about their season eight episodes
that they're doing so this is the list
and I'll preface this by saying that
even if there's not a giant pitch battle
in every single episode there still will
be crazy going on every single week
but just look at the episodes that
Miguel's upon ik is directing mr. battle
of the Basterds mr. hardhome those
episodes are probably the two big final
battles one with the night king in one
with what I think will wind up being
Team North versus team South Jamie had
that speech at the end of season 7 what
do you think is going to happen if they
do defeat the night king they're going
to turn around with their combined
armies and come south here remember it
all goes back to what they said there is
magic there is a supernatural threat but
at its core the series is about humans
versus humans so let me know what you
think about that in the comments and
whether or not you believe this Cersei
will wind up being the real big bad of
the series and if there will be some
sort of scouring of the shire type
moment scorched earth victory what that
might actually end up looking like like
remember Daenerys his vision that would
be a version of the scouring of the
shire whereby they're able to win the
day but King's Landing the north lie in
ruins after these big final battles but
because like Peter Dinklage says they're
about halfway done through filming
they'll start doing more interviews like
this and they'll start teasing stuff out
we might even get a trailer at Comic Con
this summer so just leave all your bonus
video requests in the comments below
because I will still be doing weekly
videos till season 8 actually gets here
but like I said there's a new round of
that DVD giveaway congratulations to the
winner from
last Game of Thrones video Emilia C
please private message B so I can get
your contact details you can click here
to listen to sir Davos talk about the
actual schedule for Game of Thrones and
click here to learn about what they said
at the TCAs panel in the prequel series
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight